bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france le ministère
public a requis contre vous 200 euros
damende votre avocate a plaidé la relaxe
le délibéré sera rendu le 25 mai est ce
que vous êtes confiant
bonsoir emilie bonsoir à tous
oui je suis confiant doublement
confiance d'abord je voudrais remercier
les militants et les confrères
journalistes qui sont venus nous
soutenir gérard fumex et moi ce matin et
féliciter et me féliciter aussi de la
relaxe de gérard fait mexes vous venez
d'en parler prononcés au titre de la
liberté d'informer ça me paraît
essentiel de le rappeler oui je suis
conscient que confiant parce que le
tribunal a parfaitement 4 gérard compris
qu'il s'agissait de d'assurer une
mission d'information de qualité que
pour bien faire notre travail il fallait
aller sur le tarmac sans surprise
normalement d'ici un mois je devrais
être moi moi aussi à mon tour
relaxé est ce que vous êtes étonné
d'être poursuivi
au même titre que les militants qui se
trouvait sur le tarmac de l'aéroport ce
jour là oui non étonné de devoir aller
s'expliquer jusqu'à la barre du tribunal
louis d'avoir été convoquée chez les
gendarmes
non parce qu'effectivement nous étions
en infraction avec un motif qui
semble-t-il puisque le tribunal l'a dit
ce matin est légitime celui d'assurer la
mission d'informer la pénétration était
donc de 2 sur le terrain de l'aéroport
pour un motif légitime selon le tribunal
là où je suis étonné c'est sur les
arguments que l'on nous oppose en fait
et c'est en ça que ce matin je me suis
publiquement indigné à la barre du
tribunal puisque le ministère public
nous a dit qu'il s'agissait d'une action
potash
donc il a fallu rappeler au ministère
public on n'était pas venue faire un
reportage potache mais qu'on était venue
faire un reportage sur des gens qui
estiment qu'ils ont besoin d'enfreindre
la loi pour porter un message et pour
que celui ci soit entendu donc j'ai
renvoyé le ministère public envers sa
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la société
de s'inquiéter de cette problématique là
toujours au rayon des arguments un petit
peu bizarre que le ministère public nous
nous sort à l'audience de ce matin votre
consoeur du dauphiné libéré a pu
parfaitement assuré son travail produire
un article en restant derrière la
clôture
alors ça c'est carrément incroyable
parce qu'il a fallu que la consoeur
mettre par écrit que c'est pour un
problème médical qu'elle n'a pas pu
passer sur les escabeaux et au dessus du
grillage
suivre les militants sur le tarmac et
que si elle avait pu le faire elle
l'aurait fait pour produire un travail
de qualité donc on a une consoeur qui a
reconnu que ce jour là elle n'a pas pu
produire un travail de qualité parce que
sinon le ministère public nous disait
maintenant regardez vous pouvez faire
votre travail correctement
à 500 mètres d'un lieu d'une
manifestation -celle c'est tout
bonnement incroyable et puis il ya
d'autres choses également kiki moi mon
révolté ce matin nous dit là circuit la
sécurité civile qui décolle à cet
endroit là n'a pas pu assurer une
mission de secours pendant deux heures
alors moi je réponds de choses même
trois
la première c'est que si ya pas de
journalistes ce jour là il restera quand
même les militants donc c'est pas aux
journalistes de 2,2 de payer entre
guillemets cette mise en danger s'il y
en avait une puisque l'hélicoptère
n'était pas présent ce jour là et puis
sur la durée l'action n'a pas duré deux
heures mais elle a duré 48 minutes
moi j'ai revisionné mon reportage et
sept minutes de 16 minutes de
manifestations et 32 minutes de
situation figée par les forces de
l'ordre sur le tarmac
les forces de l'ordre qui nous aurons
confié ensuite qu'il avait eu les ordres
de nous figer le temps de pouvoir monter
en puissance et d'être plus nombreux que
les manifestants et que la presse
présente ce jour-là enfants pour pour
terme ça qu'on vous a assimilé donc à
ces personnes venues à des personnes en
tout cas qui sont venus perturber
l'action des pouvoirs publics mais
pourquoi selon vous alors on nous a pas
assimilés à des personnes venues
perturber l'action des pouvoirs publics
parce que nous étions identifiables
gérard fumée que savait son brassard
avec sa carte de presse moi même j'avais
un gilet fluo identifié presse donc on
savait très bien qu'on s'adresse à des
journalistes quand on nous a convoqués à
la gendarmerie
on sait très bien qu'on était des
journalistes les gendarmes nous ont dit
bon ben écoutez vous devriez logiquement
sortir de la procédure et puis
finalement se retrouver que cette
condamnation est à la barre du tribunal
on se retrouve avec les mêmes les mêmes
reproches qu un simple militant
pourquoi je crois que c'est ce contexte
de loi de sécurité globale qui doit
monter à la tête de pas mal de personnes
on essaye de créer une presse de seconde
zone
il ya des journalistes encartés de
médias historique reconnue entre
guillemets le doigt bien sur la couture
du pantalon et puis ce jour là eh ben il
y avait gérard fumex d'un média sur
internet
très intéressé pour par la politique et
les mouvements sociaux et puis il y
avait matière à un journaliste d'une
radio associative
plutôt récente quelle bonne aubaine de
se payer deux journalistes de seconde
zone
moi je ne peux pas tolérer et je suis
indignée de de ce sous-entendu que quand
même assez fort dans les propos du
ministère public et j'ai rappelé qu' il
n'y avait pas deux catégories de
journalistes mais bien une seule et même
presse
et ce matin elle se sait front commun
dans cette mobilisation devant le palais
de justice d'annecy et ce matin
justement une cinquantaine de personnes
étaient rassemblées devant le palais de
justice d'annecy à l'appel de la
coordination stop loi sécurité globale
de la haute savoie dont pour vous
soutenir avec votre affaire en
particulier est ce que vous êtes inquiet
non de la possibilité d'exercer votre
métier correctement et d'autant plus en
vous en parler avec cette controverse à
propos de la loi sécurité globale et
bien sûr l'article 24
je crois que ce qui s'est passé ce matin
c'est qu'une fois de plus et je pense
qu'il faudra leur faire dans l'avenir
il a fallu rappeler que la liberté
d'informer la liberté 3 l'information
était ddd fondement fondamentaux pardon
pour la répétition mais qu'on ne pouvait
pas se passer de ces valeurs pour pour
avoir de l'information de qualité pour
avoir un débat démocratique de qualité
et alors ce matin pour le le cas de
gérard fumex le tribunal a compris qu'il
s'agissait d'une mission d'information
je pense que ce sera mon cas également
dans dans un mois mais jusqu'à la
prochaine fois où il faudra encore de
nouveau se battre et rappelé les
principes fondamentaux je vous rappeler
raconté juste une petite anecdote quand
on a été invité à la gendarmerie a à
s'expliquer
le gendarme première question comment
vous saviez qu'il y avait eu une
manifestation ce jour là bah écoutez je
vais répondre à vos questions sans aucun
problème je ne vais pas rentrer dans le
mutisme j'ai joué le jeu de votre
interrogatoire mais par contre sur cette
question là je ne peux pas vous répondre
parce que il y va de la protection des
sources
ah non mais vous pouvez pas commencer
comme ça dites moi au moins que c'est un
militant qui vous a prévenu
bah non non la protection des sources
est également une des valeurs
fondamentales donc on a du côté du
ministère public ou de certaines forces
de l'ordre une méconnaissance totale de
la déontologie et des valeurs et des
règles qui font que ce métier de
journaliste et est un beau métier et
qu'il faut en ce moment comme plein
d'autres métiers le défendre parce que
c'est aussi un des piliers de la
démocratie délibéré donc le 25 mai mer
si mathieu hutin je rappelle que vous
êtes persévérant chef de h2o radio et
que vous comparaissez donc aujourd'hui
devant le tribunal de police dance is
merci à vous